y
[Música]
comienza en ucrania el primer proceso
por crímenes de guerra y es contra un
soldado ruso según anunció la fiscalía
paralelamente quiere negociar con moscú
para intercambiar militares de la planta
de as hostales mariupol por prisioneros
rusos y las fuerzas ucranianas hicieron
un contragolpe en la región de jarquín
tenemos informe desde uno de los pueblos
retomados
fracaso en el senado estadounidense un
proyecto de ley para convertir el
derecho al aborto en norma federal los
50 republicanos y un demócrata se
opusieron al texto mientras crecen los
temores de que la corte suprema pueda
revocar roe versus wade tenemos análisis
en cisjordania mataron a una periodista
veterana que trabajaba para el medio al
yazira colegas que estaban con kirin abu
aquel sostienen que los militares
israelíes le dispararon mientras israel
lo niega y propone a ser parte de la
investigación del caso
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos y empecemos con la
actualidad ucraniana allí se realizará
el primer juicio por crímenes de guerra
desde que rusia invadió al país la
principal fiscal ucraniana irina
benedicto va detalló que su oficina
acusó al sargento vadim si si marín por
supuestamente haberle disparado a un
civil de 62 años en una aldea en el
noreste del país la fiscalía añadió que
está investigando más de 1.700 presuntos
crímenes de guerra cometidos
posiblemente por 600 militares rusos el
caso se conoce cuando quien reveló que
está negociando con moscú para
intercambiar militares ucranianos que
están heridos en la planta de ashurst
alén mariupol por prisioneros de guerra
rusos
otra de las novedades de este día 77 de
la guerra es una contraofensiva que
realizaron las tropas ucranianas en la
región dejar que las fuerzas armadas que
están en el área sostiene que
recuperaron cuatro aldeas en el norte y
en el noreste una de las zonas es el
pueblo de malaya arrojan muestras
enviadas irene sabio y leticia álvarez
fueron hasta allí y esta es la historia
estamos en malaya arrojan por dos meses
las tropas rusas ocuparon y atacaron
este pueblo del sur de jarquín en su
asedio a esta importante ciudad la
población local incluso vio los
barracones donde se resguardaban hasta
que el ejército ucraniano retomó el
control de la aldea
la talla pasó semanas en este sótano
mientras las tropas rusas se encontraban
en el pueblo
y de monitor si salíamos a buscar ayuda
humanitaria corríamos el riesgo de que
nos matarán podía ver a los
francotiradores desde la entrada de la
puerta de mi casa tres hombres fueron
asesinados así un hombre caminaba con su
hijo de cuatro años y también lo mataron
helicópteros abatidos hospitales
acribillados automóviles incendiados es
el paisaje de esta aldea los restos de
los combates se ven en todas partes no
queda prácticamente nadie en este pueblo
sólo las personas que resistieron a la
ocupación rusa y la artillería sigue
retumbando en roban otra aldea cercana
badín poljak tiembla al hablar del
desamparo que sintió
no entiendo aquí no hay objetivos
militares solo muchas casas en las que
viven personas no entiendo nuestra gente
vivía en paz
desde bootloader
valentina es otra superviviente nos
muestra el salón de su casa no queda
nada intacto
todavía estamos en shock y tenemos miedo
cuando oímos un ruido nos escondemos
enseguida cortan la guerra aún está
cerca de estas aldeas el ejército
ucraniano y ruso batallan por pocos
metros de tierra en un conflicto de
desgaste de final incierto y por primera
vez desde que empezó la guerra ucrania
cerró una parte del oleoducto por donde
rusia envía al menos un tercio del gas
que recibe el resto de europa el punto
temporalmente clausurado es sopranos k
ucrania alega que allí los separatistas
rusos desviaban el suministro pues es el
lugar del oleoducto está en la región de
lugansk dominada en gran parte por los
rusos desde entonces la exportada de gas
de la semiestatal rusa gazprom a través
de suelo ucraniano cayó una cuarta parte
lo que se suma a las sanciones que
impuso moscú contra el propietario de la
parte polaca del gasoducto llamado jamal
y contra la antigua unidad alemana de
gazprom
y nos vamos a eeuu el senado bloqueó el
proyecto con el que se buscaba que el
derecho al aborto se convirtiera en
norma federal la llamada ley de
protección de la salud de la mujer sólo
contó con 49 de los 60 votos que
necesitaba para ser aprobada a los 50
republicanos se opusieron y a ellos se
unió el senador demócrata joe manchin el
proyecto llegó al senado luego de que se
filtrara un borrador en el que se
estimaba que la corte suprema podría
derogar la sentencia de roe versus wait
que legaliza el aborto desde 1973 para
analizar el tema nos acompaña desde
nueva york a alejandra cárdenas ya ya es
directora de estrategias globales del
centro de derechos reproductivos un
gusto saludar la señora cárdenas con lo
que ocurrió en el senado que podría
pasar con el aborto en eeuu ya depende
únicamente de la decisión que tome la
corte suprema
en este momento desgraciadamente si
vamos a esperar cómo sale la decisión
pero si la decisión sale como el
proyecto de borrador pues vamos a
encontrarnos en la situación de que no
hay una protección constitucional a
nivel federal y que hay aproximadamente
nos ven más de 20 estados que estarían
preparados para imponer restricciones
prohibiciones totales y criminalización
y cuéntanos un poco más de qué podría
pasar en estos 20 estados que realmente
son 26 que podría pasar después de la
decisión de la corte
bueno cada estado es distinto no todos
tienen las mismas regulaciones en place
preparadas hay ocho estados que podrían
estar contemplando
penalización total a nuestros estados
que están como oklahoma o lo que pasó en
texas que están buscando
algunos sistemas como escasas
recompensas en que uno puede básicamente
como denunciar a su vecino y obtener una
recompensa si no se entera que esa
persona intento
de corrupción de embarazo y luego hay un
montón de estas que lo que tiene son los
distintos niveles de restricciones
dentro de esos aproximadamente 26
estados hay unos estados que tienen unas
fuertes protecciones pero son la minoría
y pues obviamente no sus sistemas de
salud no alcanzarían a comparar la
potencial demanda de personas de otros
estados viniendo a requerir un servicio
y ha habido protestas en frente de las
casas de tres de los jueces de la corte
y también en el tribunal de hecho el
departamento de justicia de eeuu dijo
hoy que intensificará la seguridad de
los jueces ante esto que tanta presión
representa para ellos al momento de
tomar una decisión
pues no lo sabemos porque el borrado
mismo advierte que los jueces no
deberían sentirse de ninguna manera
influidos por la opinión popular y lo
cierto es que acabar con running wilde y
con la protección del aborto en este
país es profundamente impopular más de
un 60 por ciento de la población de este
país sea ratificado constantemente en
que estarían en contra de ello y hecho
más en ese mismo 60% apoyaría la una
iniciación como la que acaba de caerse
en el senado una legislación que
protegieran y al federal el acceso a
este servicio de salud y luego de
conocerse la visita
la decisión del senado el presidente you
by the end
afirmó que la corte suprema también
podría buscar luego retroceder el
matrimonio es esto posible
la verdad que sí va a seguir la misma
línea argumentativa es posible que se
caiga no solamente el matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo sino que hay un
elenco enorme de derechos que han sido
reconocidos que estarían en peligro
porque fueron decididos con la misma
lógica y bajo el mismo principio de
derecho a la privacidad a una
constitución entre el matrimonio
interracial el mismo acceso a la
anticoncepción es en este país
gracias por estar con nosotros pasamos a
américa latina' el ciudad de méxico
decenas de activistas defensores del uso
personal de la marihuana se manifestaron
frente a la suprema corte de justicia
ellos fumaron cannabis llevaron macetas
con la planta y portaron carteles para
informar a la población sobre el consumo
responsable
méxico cuenta actualmente con
legislaciones que regulan el uso de
cannabis medicinal pero las compañías
que lo comercializan se quejan de que
estas son demasiado restrictivas
más de 100 elementos de pruebas tienen
en su poder las autoridades colombianas
paraguayas y estadounidenses que
trabajan en la investigación del
homicidio el fiscal paraguayo marcelo
pecci este funcionario estaba
especializado en narcotráfico y crimen
organizado y fue asesinado el martes
durante su luna de miel en la isla
colombiana de barú
las autoridades tienen en su poder más
de 100 elementos de pruebas que esperan
nos ayuden a encontrar a los
responsables del crimen del fiscal
paraguayo asesinado en colombia mientras
se encontraba con su esposa en una playa
turística cercana a la ciudad de
cartagena de indias
pepsi de 45 años estaba encargado de
investigar casos de narcotráfico lavado
de dinero y crimen organizado en su país
se activaron mecanismos de trabajo con
la dea con el fbi y con otras agencias
del gobierno americano esta mañana
tuvimos una mesa de trabajo donde
estuvimos intercambiando información muy
importante las autoridades estudian si
el hecho tiene relación con alguna de
las causas legales en las que trabajo
entre las que se encuentran la
investigación de ultranza una estructura
masiva de tráfico de drogas y lavado de
dinero el caso del futbolista brasileño
ronaldinho quien en 2020 intentó entrar
a paraguay con un pasaporte falso los
asesinatos del empresario mauricio
charts man y el de la hija del
gobernador de amambay el atentado de
enero en el festival de música paraguayo
jaumin a donde murieron dos personas las
autoridades colombianas anunciaron una
recompensa de 488 mil dólares a quien
presenta información que ayuda la
captura de los asesinos del fiscal es
importante que busquen a la policía que
brinden información que tengamos una
gran solidaridad de la sociedad civil
con nuestra policía con nuestras
instituciones porque la sociedad como un
todo debe combatir a los criminales
además el gobierno colombiano informó
que desplegó puestos de control en
carreteras terminales de transporte
aeropuertos y pasos fronterizos en la
investigación participan funcionarios
paraguayos colombianos y estadounidenses
la periodista irina aboga que el
corresponsal palestina estadounidense de
al yazira fue asesinada en cisjordania
los hechos ocurrieron mientras
informaban la ciudad de jenín y vestía
un chaleco que claramente decía prensa
varios reporteros que estaban en el
lugar afirman que los militares
israelíes le dispararon pero israel dice
que es pronto para saber de dónde vino
el fuego
el asesinato de shireen agua que le dejó
al mundo árabe conmocionado en ramala
miles de personas participaron en la
procesión del cuerpo de la periodista
allí manifestaron su tristeza e
indignación por el crimen hay una baile
hecho en su analista zaidín abu aquel
era una periodista muy buena es conocida
en todo el mundo árabe por lo que estoy
muy triste porque es una pérdida para
todos los periodistas árabes palestinos
americanos para todo el mundo apple es
teniendo américa azul hemos alianza mud
y otro periodista presente durante el
ataque y que resultó herido nado desde
el hospital como fueron los hechos en
los que la comunicadora perdió la vida
vertical la ocupación es asesina y
criminal nos dispararon sin razón alguna
nosotros un grupo de periodistas
estábamos allí con nuestro uniforme de
prensa completo además de los cascos con
la palabra presa escrita en letras
grandes de la unlu en doha los
trabajadores de al yazira rindieron
homenaje al trabajo de la periodista y
destacaron la importancia de seguir
informando desde cisjordania cuidado
tenemos otros periodistas valientes que
seguirán cubriendo lo que pasa en el
terreno sé que siguen estaría encantada
de que sigan trabajando esto no les
parará de dar voz a los que no tienen
varios periodistas también se reunieron
en túnez en frente de la serie del
sindicato nacional de periodistas
sabemos bien que la martín chirino era
una periodista normal sino que
denunciaba los crímenes sionistas y
todas sus prácticas racistas los
asesinatos la revolución la colonización
y los encarcelamientos siren era también
una militante que defendía la causa de
su patria el asesinato fue denunciado
como un ataque de los soldados israelíes
dirigido hacia la periodista pero israel
espera pruebas de una investigación para
pronunciarse en tri larga del presidente
gotabaya rajapaksa dijo que nombrará a
un nuevo gabinete luego de la dimisión
de su hermano y que era el primer
ministro esto en medio de las protestas
en el país por la crisis económica y el
alza del precio de combustibles y
alimentos raya pasión afirmó que
introducirá enmiendas constitucionales
para darle mayor poder al parlamento
rapear a cabo por crimen
mientras trabajo para garantizar la
seguridad del país trabajaré con todos
los líderes de los partidos para lograr
la estabilidad política en el país estoy
tomando medidas para formar un nuevo
gobierno para controlar la situación
actual para evitar que el país caiga en
la anarquía y para mantener los asuntos
del gobierno que se han paralizado
20 viene factura a la negra
sigan con nosotros
[Música]